these last few questions and I think
question 16 17 18 19 - they're all the
same category of recurrence relations
that don't just directly fall out after
integration by parts you do have to do
International parts after but there's
sometimes there's this little weed
algebraic things you got to do in there
in order to get out the exact relation
that they all have done okay so we have
a look at this your first instinct
should always be to try integration by
parts okay even if it doesn't work out
at least you learn okay I'm gonna have
to try something yours so have a look
here here's your your product so what
might you suggest would be a good choice
and draw my table what might you suggest
would be good choices for you and DV
I've got X and I've got this disastrous
thing in here one minutes excuse all ^ M
which one do you think we a better
option to choose is you this guy right
on the reason why I go for him is
because whatever I choose for DV I have
to integrate I don't really want to
integrate that okay so I'm staying away
from that as far as I can there's
another reason why you might use this is
you as you'll see in a second when I
differentiate what's the derivative
what's the UM DX your d chain rule right
so you're gonna end up with 3x squared
negative 3x squared the derivative of
the inside
but that's not all you get right I've
just on the inside so what is what
happens to the outside you get the end
that power comes down and then the power
reduces by 1 1 minus X cube to the N
minus 1 here's our other clue for why
this is a good choice for you ok that 1
minus X cubed to the N minus 1
surely that's going to be important for
our I M minus 1 here okay because that's
the difference between I am and I M
minus 1 it's just that power ok so the
fact we've differentiate it they've
gotten that sort of piece of the puzzle
there that's a good time ok good now
we've just got a simple DV and V so I've
chosen X which means that ok now you're
right to be um to be hesitant when you
see this ok because I showed you an
example of this before where you've got
this kind of scenario you've got these
two guys and I showed you and I said
this is a bad time to use integration by
parts because now look at this disaster
that results when you get you sorry V do
you but it looks like it's going to be
terrible ok but you got two things to
figure out number one think about what
would happen if you did it the other way
around
like I said integrating this is gonna be
much more difficult ok number two we're
not just doing straight integration
we're doing recurrence relations ok so
therefore you can take terms like this
right and if you can see that they're
related to some form of the integral you
can just get rid of them and not worry
about trying to evaluate them which is
exactly what's gonna happen in second ok
let's try and pull this out this is my
integral of UDV so just what is my
normal form for integration of party
well I start with UV minus VD u right
now one of the reasons why I'm going to
if I'm actually writing this out is
because this question is a little bit
different to our normal just regular
integrals it's a definite integral right
and then not so one is not there by
coincidence in fact we
need that if you've been going around
around in circles with this question
part of why it might be because you
haven't resolved the fact that that
definite integral is there for a reason
so there is a zero to one here okay that
definitely jewellers boundaries have to
appear over here as well okay so for
starters this guy is going to be
evaluated from zero to one okay and in
the same way the other interval would
one over here it has the same boundary
okay okay
good now I can actually write this out
what am I gonna get he's like you and my
babe okay so this is what goes in okay
what's my other piece it's this
monstrous thing here all right from 0 to
1 or now let's do me a super fine if we
can write I see a minus 3 over 2 you see
that then what's left in terms of the
algebra there's a single n there's an x
squared here in the next square there so
I think that mx2 the form that all right
and then you get all of this garbage
over here okay now it looks bad it does
okay stay with it for example one of the
reasons you can know you're on the right
track is because you think about what
happens to this guy right we were gonna
evaluate a minute 1 and then subtract
him evaluated at 0 right ah but look
what you've got there when you evaluate
this at 1 what happens they just
vanishes right because you stick a 1 in
there it doesn't matter what anything
else is okay so you get 0 okay you
evaluate it at 0 and the same thing
happens because of the x squared right
so you get a big fat 0 minus 0 over
there from that definite you go that's
really really good what happened to you
let's tidy up a little bit I'm
integrating with respect to X yes so
that means I don't need to worry about
anything that's not an X term in here
okay so for me that means
yes I don't need to worry about them
inside me okay and I'll just be simple
if I can see the integral without them
double negative becomes a positive I'll
have three over two and two now what
that right there should be another tick
for you right it's not arbitrary
it looks very suspicious being what you
have to prove right so being that
there's all this complicated algebra you
need to look for things like this and
this but give you clues that you are on
the right track and you've chosen the
right method that's good what's in here
not one right now we need to do
something with this
this is intractable in its current form
okay
but you have some clues as to how you
can muck around with it to make it
workable okay
clue number one is that we wanted an IM
to the minus 1 somewhere over here
didn't we
okay cuz I am is this is item okay
now that means you're gonna have a next
turn at the front and then some number
of 1 minus X cube to the end okay so
I've got the 1 minus X cubed to them
something but I don't have an X here I
think of for her exes okay no problem
that's alright we'll just take one out
and deal with him separately right so
I've got this 3n over 2 this cross
integral I've got that X at the front
that I need for it to fit in terms of
what they call capital line all right so
stick that guy there and then I've gone
next few bits left over cuz I took one
out so you got this hmm okay now if only
I didn't have this X cubed here right
that would be I n minus one wouldn't it
okay so in some cases this is a very
good situation to be in
I've gotten some part the way there but
I'm not all the way there am I how did
can I deal with this X cubed I have to
get him out
now right now the easiest way to get rid
of that X cubed is to see that well the
closest thing to an execute here is this
guy if these two can interact in some
way then I can get him out of the way I
can I can break apart that integral okay
so how do I go about doing this how do I
get him to attracted man well let's see
I'll do it over here I've got three and
okay I want that X cubed to be something
like a 1 minus X cubed right so if I had
a 1 minus X cubed here okay and that's
going to you know play index laws with
this in a minute what's the difference
between this and this there's two
differences um I'm not by a constant of
one and I'm backwards all right this is
a minus and that's a plus
no problem that's okay I can deal with
that I said I was off by a factor of a
constant of 1 okay so if I stick a 1
there these two cancel and I said on
backwards so I'll make it backwards
backwards which is the right way around
okay just stop and have a look at that
for a second because in some ways that's
the hottest step I think seeing that
this is equal to X cubed because it's 1
minus 1x that's excuse okay that is very
hard to see I think that's the trick of
this question okay because I saw this X
cube that was a problem
I wanted to interact with this 1 minus X
cube something uh and I pulled this
weird algebraic trick which is just like
with your trig identities when you
multiply and divide by the same thing
and you get a new identity out of it I
pulled that in here so that I have a 1
minus X cubed so substitute that for X
cubes now I have the rest of this here
okay watch you know how things get worse
before they get better
this is as bad as it gets everything
from here on in is going to simplify
see this um minus sign in here he's kind
of a key now because the difference of
two integrals won't remind us another I
can just break that apart I don't have a
product anymore which I can't separate
out I can just say he's wanting to go
and he's another one - the other okay so
what would be the first integral well
it's still got a three and it's you at
the front it's still from naught to one
all right let's have a look here maybe
to make a little bit easier for you I'll
put this X back inside watch X times 1
is X X times 1 minus X cubes is that now
to break your pot I've got the first
pairing x times out okay so I've got X
times advance there's one integral done
finished then I do the next one starts
with a - so I better start with the -
right but he still has all of this stuff
carried with him still got a 3n over 2
out the front it's still from naught to
1 but it's not next anymore it's X 1
minus X cubed okay so that there that's
this parent okay - pairings two
integrals have a look at this here what
is it
that's a n minus one isn't it matches
exactly the only difference is the power
okay so therefore a 3n over 2
I am minus 1 that's really good ok what
do I have here I've got one - execute
here I've got n minus 1 of them there so
how many do I have in total I've got in
of them if I've got ed of them then this
is x times 1 minus X cube to the end
exactly this exactly that no difference
that's I am okay this whole thing who's
I am right and I want a relationship
between I am nine minutes but I want my
end to be the subject so I just
rearranging the myth tidy up this have
two of these over here get all your
items on one side so your ad got three
of them these guys are pretty much there
aren't I how many in total three and
plus two of them three of these and then
you just divide after which you collapse
in a heap and think he's serious
um this is tribute what was hard about
this question many many fittings right
so for this reason I would expect this
to be like you know right at the end of
an exam paper just like it's at the end
of an exam if you were to get such a
question the first thing that was hard
is that it looks like the former is this
integration by parts it looks like it
okay but if you stay with it
noting this definite integral just makes
all of that you vanish right and then
see that you needed to get rid of this
through this we treat okay the rest of
it kind of falls out so I think your two
pressure points
ah here and staying with that being
confident this is going to go somewhere
right which gets you to here and then
your second pressure point is working
out how to resolve this guy it's almost
like a trig identity climbed on in the
way that you have to sort of conjure up
I should add one and take one away and
turn the thing backwards so that these
two can go together okay